let's get into our favorite segment of
the week the wild money moves of the
week let's get wild we got a few things
we're going to power through them so
basically here's the first story
americans
there's good news and bad news here it
is so americans have been going on a
spending spree since 2021.
2020 they saved that money 2021 they
spending that money here's some stats
for you the good news here
americans saved a lot more than usual
during the pandemic basically 2020 the
first year of it
in fact 1.6 trillion was saved well when
you're giving out you know five trillion
dollars in stimulus and unemployment
nonsense and whatever it's kind of easy
to start saving that money especially if
you're on lockdown you don't want places
to go but here's the bad news since 2021
since the
vaccine and everything's been rolling
out americans misspending that money in
fact americans are spending on average
a month
more than they did in 2020. so if you
spend typically a thousand bucks a month
now you're spending 1700 bucks a month
okay if you spend 500 bucks a month now
you're 1200 bucks a month okay and you
know who shocker alert you know who's
spending the most gen z and millennials
yeah
you did it you knit the nail on the head
so basically younger folks gen z
millennial they're leading the charge on
spending now where the average american
is spending 765 dollars a month more
than they did last year going out having
the time of their lives
gen z millennials are now spending a
thousand dollars
versus the average american spending
additional that's essentially they're
spending an additional thousand dollars
a month save that money spend that money
in this case and where do you think
they're spending that money young david
i don't know i have a lot of questions
going through my like how much of that
is
because of inflation how much is like no
no no it's not it's not inflation that's
just money out of pocket well yeah more
money because where are they spending
the money where do you think these young
millennials these 20-something
30-somethings are going to be the answer
is gonna be something dumb like amazon
or clothes or games or going out
drinking food beverage there it is food
and beverage there it is they're going
out
you know the big three of spending money
eating stuff drinking stuff or seeing
stuff
they're dining out they're going out to
bars they're going out to clubs clubs
are open again bars are open again right
or they're traveling they're going on
vacation especially since things are on
lockdown which on under which what you
might be saying like well duh you
haven't been able to go out in a year
yeah exactly time to get your yolo on
right yeah which i understand but yeah
that this like could have seen coming
from
right in the beginning well you know
when you're on lockdown and you and
you're basically pent up demand you're
pent up i got to get the hell out of
this house and you're basically staring
death in the face or at least you
thought kovid turns out 99
of
people are not
dying 99.9
unless you're old unhealthy or some very
tragic situations uh you're seeing you
know staring the face of death you're
seeing bad things all around you
basically that yolo mentality starts to
kick in oh it's yolo time bro yeah
we gotta get to the club
i gotta i'm i i gotta i got a hole in my
pocket i'm burning i i'm burning to
spend money right yeah it's burning up
yeah same thing music festivals are sold
out all of them packed i went to this
thing three points in miami yeah and
first time going but all i heard before
was like oh it's never been this packed
so yeah people are pent up they want to
be out they want to go to music
festivals they want to do things and
they're going to spend a ton of money
so
look a lot of the money as we talked
about this extra thousand dollars a
month is others this extra 765 dollars a
month i get it a lot of it is going to
food and beverage eating and drinking or
going out traveling i get it okay
you know they're almost like they're
locked up they said if i'm gonna die i
ain't dying cooking in my kitchen i'm
going out yeah okay
but understand you know i say that
there's three big things three big
expenses in your budget if you can
manage these three big things you're
gonna be all right financially
housing where you live transportation
how you get around and your f and b your
food and beverage what you eat and drink
and if housing maybe you're not paying
rent right now maybe your you know
family's helping you live you know
you're splitting the cost of roommate
maybe you're not you know you're working
from home and you're not traveling as
much okay maybe maybe maybe maybe but
food and beverage they say it's death by
a thousand bites so in this case right
now
this food and beverage going out
drinking traveling partying having the
time of your life is costing you yeah on
average an extra 10 12 grand a year yeah
okay so when you have when you have
three-fourths of american live in
paycheck to paycheck 50 of people don't
have 500 bucks for an emergency fund
right
and
80 of people don't have a thousand bucks
saved
and you're spending all your money on
food and beverage yeah
dude i went through my finances uh last
week and i noticed
all of my money was going out to was
going to lunches here when i ordered
food or going out drinks
i stopped doing that it was this i did
this like two two weeks ago i stopped
doing that i've saved
so much money yeah because i started
just cooking at home bringing things in
not going out for drinks if i go out
with friends i don't get alcohol maybe
i'll just get you know the food yep
100 that's for you hold on keep talking
a hundred percent food and beverage
that'll eat up your finances literally i
think that's the biggest biggest one
because your housing and your your
transportation those are fixed they're
pretty much fixed yes so all you really
have to control is the food and beverage
once you have once you have that under
under wraps
[Music]
it's it's saved that money it saves that
money that money here are 10 things that
are killing your wealth here we go i did
an episode on uh valuetainment economics
one time 10 things that are killing your
wealth
and number four was eating out here's
some stats for you just because we're
gonna go ham on the whole eating drink
and dining fine dining we're gonna go
ham on it right so the average american
household spends 3k a year 250 bucks a
month
on eating out okay so the average meal
at home is four bucks the average meal
out is 13 bucks that's a nine dollar
difference i was actually have a
conversation with one of our friends
here that should remain nameless he says
every single day
he orders lunch every day maybe dinner
so that's on average 13 15 bucks a pop i
said you know he gets chipotle
chick-fil-a whatever he's getting yeah
so on average let's call it that's 30
bucks a day that's boom boom boom boom
thirty bucks a day
nine times fives it's five days that's
150 bucks it's almost 200 bucks a week
it's 800 bucks a month
okay eating out so he's like this is
killing me man this is killing me so
um
it's five times more expensive to order
delivery by the way than just eating out
oh yeah so like when i'm talking about
eating out like maybe you just roll up
to a place and get a meal 12 bucks 13
bucks if you're gonna order delivery
over eating
now you're 20 bucks 22. okay
so and if you're doing it every day
lunch let's say it's 10 bucks a day
maybe 15 bucks a day okay
times five days a week that's three
grand a year you don't understand what's
going on so you want to treat yourself
you want to treat yourself cool do it on
a special occasion do it on a birthday
do it on a date not every single day
yeah it's not a treat that happens every
day you know like i've heard that before
it's not a party if it happens every
night every day so it's like yeah treat
yourself
like you said special occasions weekends
all maybe you know anyway um
seems like i'm a little angry today i'm
not i'm here for you i'm actually very
i'm very happy very happy 100th episode
pbd podcast we're doing it but you know
when you see people under you know
overspending
i get it you know we've saved a lot
during the pandemic now it's time to
spend that money
you're kind of making up for lost time i
get it but just don't get caught up in
that lifestyle you want to go out have a
nice dinner cool respect do your thing
but uh understand that that is money
that is going out the door talk is money
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay bro
[Music]